welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of house of
the dragon episode 2 where marrying a 12
year old is unspeakable but a 15 year
old hey well so long as she brings you
toys viserys is like that's what i love
about these westeros girls man i get
older they stay the same age the look of
the series just gets better and better
so let's break down the cool visual
details the deeper layers of meaning you
might have missed starting with because
i am crazy what exactly is going on in
this opening title sequence it's set to
remain jawat's game of thrones theme
music using the same song does cynically
suggest the petty games played by the
westerosians 200 years from now are the
same ones about to be played by these
a-holes compared to the map imagery of
the game of thrones opening this one
uses stone dials as blood snakes through
each dial forming a symbolic chain of
violence be getting violence but also a
family tree a literal bloodline each
dial represents a specific member of the
targaryen family tree the fact that it's
a dial that turns suggests that with
each link of this chain could
directionally change the vector of the
bloodline based on what their moral
alignment is notice the recurring crown
on many of these dials this is the one
worn by viserys and before him jiharis
this is the crown of aegon the conqueror
this crown represents whoever the king
is on that generational tier and you'll
notice that crown is usually paired with
another dial representing a merit union
the blood drowning each dial represents
these rulers deaths but that death be
getting a new generation of bloody
rulers the first style of course is
aegon's dial depicting dragonstone
swarmed by dragons these dragons are not
a loving family but rather in combat
with each other according to the audio
description thus we are going to begin
every episode of the show with dragon vs
dragon the gates of dragonstone pop
upward and the tableau sinks allowing
blood to pour in and blood to flood
outward to drown the whole realm this
blood river forks down a wall with
engravings showing dragons torching
infantry cavalry and archers this is
likely aegon's conquest and it flows
into two dials representing aegon's two
sisters rhaenys and visenya then onto
another dial that floods this is
rhaenys's son aenes now notice we do not
see a dial for megor the cruel as that
would be the zenith sun and be on the
other side of that left dial that we saw
before then the bloodline zips to two
paired dials for jiharis and alisan the
blood explodes then into branches as the
targaryen family tree did at this point
we glide upward to two dials that are
already drowned in blood for jaehaerys's
late son balon and his wife alyssa who
are viserys parents the blood river now
pours off a ledge while in the
background it snakes toward a blue
colored wall with a dial showing the
valyrian sea horse for coreless velaryon
so the blood that the dial touches here
is rhaenys aemon's daughter the queen
who never was who gets married to
corliss meanwhile another branch of the
river flows into a crown dial that does
not flood that represents the current
king viserys unflooded because he's
still alive for now beside him is
essential for house aaron flooded for
emma aaron his late wife who died in
episode one but notice though that
viserys's bloodline branches to the left
toward that green wall where the greens
aka the hightowers are we're telling
viserys moving on to alison in this
episode then we cut to a shot where the
bloodline flows into a dial with the
house hightower lighthouse representing
alicent soon to be queen and you'll
notice that the level above her is a
dial representing her father otto now
next we see three interlocking circles
of the valerian steel necklace that
damon gave renera last episode this one
obviously representing renera this style
rising high above the blood to stay
untouched by it then we quickly pass
under a gate showing a dragon fanning
its wings over the houses of westeros
believe those sigils are baratheon
hightower blackwood dustin star pike
lannister valerion stark and then maybe
greyjoy some of these are important some
of them are lower houses whatever they
all look cool lastly we see that all of
these dials rest upon the layers of
viserys's stone model of valyria proving
our theory correct last episode that
that model might be part of the new
opening title sequence running down the
middle of that model you can see
pairings representing the marriages
through the ages through which the royal
lineage ran but then closer to the
bottom of it a few isolated ones where
the bloodline ends because we are not
yet sure which of these characters will
bear the heirs to the crown but we are
sure if you look at a family tree just
don't you'll spoil yourself and yes i
will be monitoring the sequence closely
or updates to it as characters die or
produce new errors because i'm crazy and
we end the main title showing the golden
targaryen sigil all of these blood
rivers feeding the fire beneath fire and
blood the targaryen house words in the
title the novel that this is based on
the opening shot shows two hands impaled
on wood as crabs picket them this
parallels the gnawing the flesh from
king viserys's hand by maggots later
from a nameless casualty to the king
himself these are all corpses on
borrowed time everybody knows that
mental health is important which is why
it's so frustrating that once you decide
to see a therapist finding one is so
difficult well better help makes that
process way easier this video is
sponsored by better help if you think
you might be feeling depressed stressed
anxious or overwhelmed better help is
here to help betterhelp offers licensed
therapists who are trained to listen and
help you better help allows you to
message your therapist in a private
online environment at your convenience
better helps network has over 20 000
therapists with a broad range of
expertise and specialties giving you
access to help that may not be available
in your area just fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs and you'll be matched
with the therapist in under 48 hours
once you are matched you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions and
exchange unlimited messages everything
you share is completely confidential and
if you ever want to request a new
therapist you can at any time with no
additional charge over three million
people have taken charge of their mental
health with an experienced better health
therapist if you are interested in
improving your mental health with better
help you can get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com new rockstars or click
the link in the description that's
b-e-t-t-e-rhelp.com
new rockstars for 10 off your first
month crabs pick at a barnacled skull
like the barnacled bust in corliss's
chamber later at the end of the episode
this dramatic crucifixion imagery we are
seeing now is really through corliss's
existential fear this is his song of ice
and fire or really we should say i guess
his song of sea and crabs crabs pick at
a gash on a man's foot his bone is
exposed but he stirs he's still alive
he's being eaten alive by crabs as a
victim of kragus the crab theater leader
of the triarchy ravaging the stepstones
currently the wide shot shows that these
stakes are set up in the path of the
tidal river where crabs would come in
like the opening titles a river of blood
bringing death but we smash cut to
another red river an overhead shot of an
empty cup as rhaenyra pours in wine the
red liquid pouring into a golden pit
like the blood pouring into the
targaryen sigil in the opening credits
the small council is discussing the
death of sir ryan redwine that bearded
lord commander of the kingsguard who
appeared in the background last episode
corliss comes in late wanting to hit
back at craigs and his triarchy who are
funded by the free cities many of which
we saw in game of thrones including
braavos lorath leese mir norvos pentos
cohort tyrosh and volantis notice how
master of coin lyman beesberry says in
all of its history my lord the seven
kingdoms have never entered open wall
with the free cities what reason does
the crab feeder have to fear us
yeah corliss is focusing his anger on
moneybags beastbury a man who likely
takes money from the iron bank located
where the free city of braavos major
conflict of interest on this small
council and notice throughout this
meeting corliss's punch card ball stays
on the centerpiece it's never moved to
his plate reflecting how he was never
really part of this meeting and at the
end of this episode we'll leave this
council when ronira gets booted from the
meeting for pitching the one good idea
the doors are shut behind her closing
her out and homage to the final shot of
the godfather where michael shuts out k
sir harold goes through the kingsguard
candidates each represented by a
figurine some ornamented ceremony to
mark the seriousness of the king's guard
in this era consistent with the way the
show uses dials and balls and other
tokens to represent people everyone is a
piece on a game board there's sir
desmond karen sir raymond mallister
house corbre house craicall and house
tarly otto reminds us the malistas of
seaguard protect against the reavers
from the iron islands referring to the
greyjoys sir kristin has no heraldry
because while he comes from house coal
of the stormlands he's actually a
dornishman notice how his figurine is a
simple pillar unadorned otto lurks in
from behind while rainey swatches from
the balcony more interested in how the
named heir makes her first official
decision in all the shots of raniero
with otto rhaenys can be seen snooping
in the background because this queen who
never was is deducing that if rhaenyra
was booted from the small council
meeting she and her husband cordless
might be able to play to the king's
succession anxieties get our 12 year old
in a hair and make up stat rainier
inquires you saw combat in the
stormlands dornish marches princess i
fought for a year as a foot soldier
against the dornish incursions siral and
dondarrion knighted me after we raised
two of the watchtowers along the burnway
the dornish marches are areas between
the stormlands and dorne the boneway is
a treacherous pass to the red mountains
aegon the conquerors attempt to conquer
dorne actually failed this campaign
killed his sister wife ray niece and her
dragon miraxis and now rhaenyra offering
cyrax to the stepstones and wanting a
kingsguard has actually seen combat
rhaenyra is a natural wartime ruler
viserys describes valyria the
dragonlord's the highest of the nobility
lived here
the volcanic face closest to the source
of their magic and power and this was
the inaugural where the blood mages
worked their craft the doom of illyria
was believed to be an eruption of the 14
flames a chain of volcanoes
interconnected by mines that all erupted
simultaneously and sunk the whole
peninsula many believe this might have
been triggered by magic either by
accident or by design the zera says the
glory of old valyria will never be seen
again
so viserys bleakly believes that
humanity's best days are behind them
while breaking a dragon figurine
reflecting his house's broken future he
dropped it though because of his wounded
finger which is also visible bandaged
during his speech to raniere at the end
of last episode a literal form of his
family's unhealable wound the lie of
their dragon power and their mad dreams
but the low sun silhouettes viserys and
allison here it actually hangs low
throughout the episode foreshadowing
viserys's sun setting rain and nearly
every shot of viserys even in the
close-ups the hilt of his valerian steel
dagger pokes up in the frame aegon's
song of ice and fire always on his mind
alice and rhaenyra prey in the sept
above the altar is a statue of one of
the seven the audio description calls it
a woman suggesting this is the mother
which makes sense because they are both
praying to their dead moms at times we
cut to a high angle of these two with
the mother statue not visible in these
frames meaning we are seeing these two
daughters from the point of view of the
mother above alison places her hand on
raniere's arm and you could see
allison's thumb is still raw from her
picking at it these past six months of
lying to her friend about moving in on
her dad have filled her with anxiety
even this supposedly sweet moment
between the two friends is actually
manipulation that was at vazaris request
when i wish to talk with him
i know that i must make the effort
corliss asks viserys again to intervene
at the step zones dropping this line to
elude a storm you can either sail into
it
or around it
but you must never await its coming it's
a really great analogy for a seafarer
who's adrift on a vessel but not for a
land-bound castle dweller like viserys
the guy who gave up dragon riding years
ago and now just sits in place in fear
of a blizzard that is unavoidable
according to his
great-great-grandfather's dream while
viserys and rhaenyra dine his model of
valyria frames them in the foreground
viserys is trying to prop up his dynasty
upon the ruins of valyria also the
secret moments that he's been sharing
with allison is what is bringing this
father and daughter together it's almost
like allison is in the room with them
chaperoning them now viserys's small cut
last episode has completely festered
into this infection do they not have
bandages seriously a freaking paper cut
but no this is further proof that the
cuts from the iron throne are uniquely
unhealable and cursed in a way there
actually is a long-running theory that
the archmaesters who hail from old town
along with the hightowers old town being
the former seat of power and westeros
before the targaryens arrived these
maesters could be conspiring in an
illuminati type plot to weaken the power
of the dragons and the influence of
magic in the world with science-backed
duplicitous advice and medical
malpractice think about it there is a
maester in every castle and they all
talk to each other could that be
connected to the message that otto sent
back to old town now now now we hear new
rock stars have to admit that what we
call conspiracy is often more likely
incompetence but i don't know the king's
slow rot could be one of these deaths by
design that melos warned of last episode
otto's necklace is a chain it's designed
reminiscent of the chains worn by the
citadel maesters maybe he is another
link in the chain and that all of these
old town oldies are connected but i do
like how we see the difference in his
tactics compared to his rival corliss
they both have the same strategy
ultimately they're both trying to push
their two young daughters on the widower
king to raise their family station but
while corliss aggressively pushes his
agenda and doesn't make any secrets
about it otto is sneaky he just kind of
slips his daughter into the room and
uses his own dead wife to appeal to
viserys grief and to be compelled to
replace her for duty's sake
you are the king
but i do not envy you in rhetorical
criticism this tactic is called
enthymeme it's an art of persuasion in
which you never explicitly state what
you want the person to do you just use a
highly charged emotional argument so
that they draw the conclusion in their
own heads and they think it was their
own idea so the two young liana chats
with viserys about the lost dragon
veigar that was a massive still-alive
dragon written by aegon's sister white
vizinia but vague arsenal lives
somewhere the workers of spice town
reports hearing her song at times
they say it is a sad thing
i imagine even dragons get lonely now of
course cesaros is actually talking about
his own loneliness and these talking
points were truly fed to lana by her
father corliss who falsely assumes that
viserys is lonely because he no longer
rides a dragon valerion so maybe by
hinting driftmart folk know where vegar
is that could be a benefit that house
valerion could give the crown but not so
fast because what the valyrians don't
really realize is that viserys thinks
dragons shouldn't exist at all they're
all too large for the world behind
rainer and rhaenys is more smutty
artwork what looks like a hookup between
humans and a dragon it was actually
believed that among the dark magic
practiced by the blood mages of old
valyria was cross-breeding humans with
dragons so all that messed up stuff that
led to the doom of valyria is now being
celebrated by their doomed descendants
and the red keep allison's gift of the
fixed dragon figurine is perfect for
viserys a symbol of her ability to mend
the fractures of his family but also it
represents dragons as he wishes they
would be lifeless cast in stone and
small enough to fit in his hands as he
holds a figurine notice how it covers
the hilt of aegon's dagger but when duty
comes to knock him viserys stiffens and
the dagger sticks out now and he deepens
his voice come
i mean come on this castle has literal
bestiality porn on every surface don't
tell me that there's not sexual
undertones to otto walking in on these
two the dragon keeper reports in
delirian
yes there's a westerosi custom of naming
the hours of the night after animals the
hour of the bat is right after sunset so
after we saw the master of sneaks
sneaking around last episode demon
proves once again that he knows maegor's
secret passageways in king's landing
that no one else does rainier asks
scorio drum monday men light us
so dream fire was a dragon ridden by
rayna older sister to jiharis reyna
married their brother aegon and they
were attacked by maegor when he made a
bid for the throne when aegon died
maegor took reina as one of his black
brides so there is a history and dream
fire being used as a kind of pawn in
these games by these rogue princes
grasping for the throne as we swoop into
the foggy dragonstone we pass the crown
flagship with a mounted dragon head on
the bow as well as grasping dragon claws
maybe these help prevent the ship from
crashing against the rocks this meetup
on the bridge between otto's detachment
and demon's gold cloaks is framed from
overhead almost like two bloodlines
meeting midstream like in the opening
credits only one bloodline could
ultimately flow forth the other is
damned like you saw what i did there
like you know damned up but also like in
damnation notice how damon's first
gesture here is to toss the egg casually
from one hand to the other if he truly
cared about this egg as a nest mate for
his baby he would not be so loose with
it proving that this is all really a
stunt he asks where is the king i don't
see him his grace would never lower
himself to entertain such a mum as fast
ah the reaction shots sir harold was in
frame when otto stopped viserys from
going himself now he notes that otto
wanted the win for himself or maybe otto
really wanted the king to be left alone
with his daughter for a night but then
the dragon karaxis enters
so this series distinguishes its dragons
much better than game of thrones did not
only by appearance and color but in the
way they sound our colleague joanna
robinson on the ring verse podcast
quoted paula fairfield who created the
dragon sound design for both game of
thrones and house of the dragon
fairfield said caraxie's whistles and
clicks were based on a specific mix that
she made for young drogon in that
episode of astapor in game of thrones
[Music]
fairfield also said that miguel
sapochnick said caraxies should sound
like a dragon with a deviated septum she
actually expanded with her own hilarious
backstory for the dragon notice as
karaxi's roars he can actually see down
his gullet and how his windpipe quivers
in this awkward way to produce this
sound as a deviated septum would but the
fact that sound designer considered this
a pathetic love song for cyrax tells us
that damon's true affections may reside
with his niece notice how crazy still
wears his targaryen mark saddle these
dragons are always wearing their saddles
even when they're not being ridden in
that moment as an attempt to tame them
but also to let all others know who
these wmds answer to or at least they
want them to think they answer to them
then we hear a second roar
the fog parts like ocean waves like the
crestine of a great white shark or
godzilla as cyrax passes the low sun the
sun's dim light peeks through its
translucent wings a visual effect
interacting with the physical
environment to make it more lifelike i
love it rhaenyra confronts her uncle
siculant
rasilati to me
earlier otto called this a mummer's
farce and rhaenyra sees right through
these theatrics mazaria is not pregnant
therefore there's no crib for the dragon
egg this is actually a change from the
book where mazzaria is with child so
this way damon is more of an agitator
and rhaenyra is a bolder fixer damon
consoles mazaria in a room that actually
looks a lot like the one in game of
thrones that contains aegon's painted
table of the map of westeros that table
would exist at this point in history it
was created by aegon but it's not in
this room right now maybe it's a
different room that just looks a lot
like it or there's a shop from a glassy
surface in the foreground maybe that is
a painted table it's just tucked in a
corner before announcing his marriage
intentions to the small council notice
viserys is gazing out the window at the
dragonpit we're telling how this
decision will lead to the dance of the
dragons that will turn dragon against
dragon in the years to come viserys
first checks in with his daughter good
gods once again the reaction shots are
perfect i intend to marry
the lady alison hightower
yes just by how long her father's
looking at her you can see the smile
just slightly fade from her near his
face as she suspects something but then
viserys looks at allison and alison
looks at renera and from that rainier
already knows before he says anything
that these two formed a relationship
without her knowing and as the tears
well up in her eyes rhaenyra connects
the dots allison's constellations of the
sept were all manipulations she has no
friend her father didn't really know her
at all and even the hall she storms out
into is lying to her because they forgot
to digitally remove some of the blue
screen there then on a drift mark on
corliss's desk are sea maps with
compasses there's a dragon skull various
seashells then this barnacled bust that
i mentioned before a visual reminder for
corliss of the fate of his men in the
stepstones which this episode circles
back to as craigs nails a man to the
stake to feed it to the crabs cordless
says
we are the realm's second son stamen
our worth is not given
it must be made
now corliss does not have an older
brother but he's referring to house
velaryon being the metaphorical younger
brother to house targaryen the valerians
passed over because they are not dragon
lords now this episode's title is the
rogue prince from george rr martin's
2014 novellette about prince damon and
his relationship with viserys this
episode's new bloodline themed opening
suggests that this dynasty was formed by
marriages but really if anything stable
marriages have been the exception to the
rule maegor was a rogue prince who stole
the iron throne from its rightful
lineage the rightful reignist was passed
over for another rogue prince viserys so
damon really knows that his is a family
of rogue princes and ultimately fortune
will favor the bold follow me on tik tok
instagram and twitter at voss subscribe
to rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you